welcome to the new icarly we'll help
however we can i'm really glad to hear
you say that
damn it wake up the members of icarly
nation
the trailer for the upcoming revival
series dropped on tuesday and gave fans
a glimpse of the new icarly
here we go people are weirdly loving
this
i don't think this is how you do it
icarly will pick up nearly 10 years
after nickelodeon's original show
ended and the cast is all grown up the
trailer features
original stars miranda cosgrove jerry
trainor
and nathan kress returning to their
roles this is not how i imagined my life
as well as newcomers jaden triplett who
plays freddie's stepdaughter
i have a kid now so that's you know that
changes
the dynamic a little bit and lacey
mosley will be playing carly's new best
friend harper
somewhat replacing jeanette mccurdy who
played sam on the og
show but has since quit acting this is
your moment to shine
you need to be a trailblazer like an
effortless trailblazer like i just got
out of bed was all
oops i just blazed a trail in addition
to carly's dreams of becoming an
effortless trailblazer
the video also teases both carly and
freddie trying their luck in the dating
world
maybe you just need some arm candy of
your own and i have the perfect guy
yeah we're done so does this mean carly
and freddie's goodbye kiss in the
original show series finale meant
nothing
tbd i don't know
i have no idea and even if i didn't know
i wouldn't tell you
we gotta we gotta keep things spicy for
the folks at home
right miranda too juicy too juicy to say
the paramount plus revival series which
premieres on june 17th
also teases the return of some fan
favorites like baby spencer
and neville paperman played by reed
alexander
e.t caught up with the og crew at this
year's kids choice awards where they
ditched
secrets about the icarly show the three
of us got back together and was like
just riding a bike it was like we're
back
it feels kind of crazy we did the first
table read about a week or so ago
and it was kind of insane like just
getting everybody back together again
and it was really fun did you find were
you like
was it easy for you i kind of thought it
was yeah yeah
the cool part is what makes it different
too is we have new characters that are
coming as well so it is
a lot of the familiar you know it's a
lot of familiar faces but there's new
people involved that are gonna change up
the story a ton
and make it very interesting uh and i
think somewhat
unexpected see i feel like there's a lot
of secrets yeah we don't know
when we're gonna get in trouble for uh
saying too much i'll say the scripts are
really funny
i don't think anybody's expecting
what we're doing what we're doing i just
don't think
it's i don't think a revival's been done
quite this way